yeah what came up to this video in plane
because power of MH 99 so player
strategical opening the double of your
shadow quite good results with that yeah
we have new transposing to an English
opening now symmetrical English he can
play the 65 though it's an interesting
move okay retweet the Queen c7 is
usually quite bad place for the Queen
the structures bishop okay
I maybe can play Bishop you fool no have
taken note hmm yeah well this is really
a bad setup it's 95 Roxy 195 he will
move you we need to move the Queen again
and I can take on your six first Bashar
Essex it's not matter any weight 195 I
can even take with the pawn it surf this
is better even the eye is playing every
move instantly of course it's very easy
this game um okay
yeah h3 is a positive he needs to play a
fire now I go for that yeah for winning
quite a good amount of space if he needs
to if he plays f5 it's really a weakness
but may be necessary he cannot really
you can't move the Queen I put the other
night back on this heaven but this
doesn't look very very inviting as well
check
and now just take the c fob
yeah it's simply a quite substantial
space advantage it's very hard for black
to equalize this completely
yeah d 6 p-6 em yeah it just gives me c
6 this is six square okay you have g4 is
one good possibility you know it's a
great grab space
g5 yeah an IG for furthering night h6
meeting so he cannot he cannot take so
maybe just a weight can either cannot
play this is long this is probably
observed the ideas just too yeah this is
chang this is a fog black resigns yeah
that him I'm sorry but he made so many
positionally terrible moves and I cannot
be six for example you absolutely this
is like resignation if you need to play
b6 giving away all those squares and
done and it wasn't necessary I mean
black is worse in this position no doubt
but why not play something else Queen a
five for example I mean this is still a
game I'm only I'm better but it's not
nothing special maybe this is a the
defense v6 is just you cannot play that
it's just giving away all squares and no
counter play allowing g5 is also quite
quite remarkable
yeah this is this is a movement at I
always thought Quinn here and drop c7 he
has that I have winner for gathers
symmetrical positions are they they have
some some some poison and them it's not
so such an easy easy game for black
um-hum he really needed to play an
active move here like like we near five
alright thanks for watching